as home sales slow Realtors go back to
other jobs as home sales Realtors this
is not like a regular article Breitbart
this is Wall Street Journal right so
home sales are slowing because of
interest rates interest rates but
wouldn't so wouldn't the home so every
people still want to demand but but it's
not interest rates it's a good question
you ask okay it's greed it's not
interest rates it's great there's a
house in our community that I'm trying
to uh uh buy for somebody in my family
okay they're asking 1.294 they were
asking 1.7 million a year and a half ago
so they went to 1.6 1.5 1.4 now it's
1.29 that house is worth 7.50
but they're asking 1.29 okay so the 1.29
is these families every month or every
two months that they lower a hundred
thousand dollars guess what they're
starting to realize this is not worth
1.7 million anymore okay this is
probably going to end up selling for 900
000 800 000 so it's not interest rates
High interest rates are given a reality
check to homeowners that are being
greedy thinking wait for it we can sell
it for more wait for it we can sell it
for more wait for we can sell it for
more on a [__] pay blower by a hundred
grand lower by 100 Grand so it's greed
that's causing these Realtors to leave
because Realtors today don't know how to
tell the client Jimmy can I tell you
something yes what is it you're going to
get upset when I tell you this Jimmy
what's that your house is not worth 1.5
million this is a 900 000 house what's
the reaction Jimmy's gonna have you know
what now Jimmy I'm gonna leave I'm the
realtor I'm trying to give some common
sense here when I leave guess what
Jimmy's wife's gonna say babe Fire
Patrick immediately he's Clueless then
he's going to call the next realtor and
any realtor is going to say what just
like any guy says on a date with a girl
I'm gonna change your life and the
realtor is going to say Patrick has no
clue what he's this is at least a 1.55
million dollar home then you hired that
Realtor then a realtor 90 days later
guess what that Realtor has to tell
Jimmy Jimmy I have to break it to you
yeah this is an 800 000 house so it's
the relationship between the realtor and
the client right now that's the conflict
Realtors don't know how to break it to
the client that this house is not what
you think it's worth I don't think it's
just a rate can I add one thing real
quick by the way when we're talking
about the realtors that are going back
to other jobs we're not talking about
the top 10 percent of Realtors top 20
we're not even talking about the top 50
we're talking about all the guys and
gals that was saw what was happening in
2020 and like hold on let me get on the
bandwagon and they were cook chefs Uber
drivers whatever
photographers whatever and they got
their real estate license by the way I
did the same thing in 2005 when I saw
everybody making money in real estate in
Miami I'm like oh I want to get my real
estate license then came 2008 crash all
right I'm done being a realtor so all
these FL fake flyby night Realtors
they're out and then it's the people who
are experts at this it's almost like the
people that want to start a podcast
everyone's doing a podcast next thing
you know you know times get tough all of
a sudden people drop out of the podcast
world it's the people who are in it for
longevity and the right reasons are
still in it so shout out to those
Realtors the people who are in it for a
quick Buck they're out of it so you
think I'm okay I don't have to worry
about where I put my money I think you
just keep in an annuity you're good what
yeah or for what time frame 10 years
five years three years it's very
different if you have no plans with your
401k over a 10-year period maybe look at
the allocations pay attention to it
closely you don't want to have your
stocks in 100 small cap stocks I don't
know what what type of equities you got
uh you know if you got the index and I
don't know what kind of annuity if it
was a variable annuity or an index
annuity or a fixed annuity those are
three different types of annuities you
got a straight up fix them what was the
rate they gave you so it was five
percent but then after the fees it
actually turns out to be like three but
wasn't there a locked up period if you
look up if you look up an index annuity
what an index annuity does is made for
Boomers an index annuity would be you
can get the upside of how to Market us
up to a percentage so they'll say like
hey if the market does 38 you're capped
at 12. okay but if the market does minus
38 percent like 2008 guess what you're
not losing anything you stay at zero so
it gives you to zero to twelve so an
index annuity was designed specifically
for Boomers and it gave the Best of Both
Worlds a fixed annuity and a variable I
feel good about that yeah
just do yourself a favor take all the
money go to Vegas put it all on black
baby what is it self-directed 401K what
is that or you can choose your
allocation strategy my brother says he
puts it into real estate
you know instead of putting it into the
stock market he does a 401k somehow
where he puts it into real estate is
that possible of course it is yeah yeah
to REITs you can put gold in your 401k
you can do 100 gold in your 401k really
did you hear me Peter Thiel did with his
401k or this Roth he really he's became
a billionaire I mean the way he did it
that's not the average person Jimmy so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]